[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de América Latina
y el mundo entre mayo y junio 3
destacados medios de comunicación de
América Latina han cerrado sus
operaciones esto debido a diversos
factores como la falta de sostenibilidad
financiera que también según denuncian
son producto del hostigamiento y
persecución de los gobiernos de turno
hablamos con una de sus periodistas
vamos a empezar en Venezuela tras 93
años al aire radio Caracas radio la
emisora más antigua del país apaga su
señal de manera definitiva la decisión
se dio ante la imposibilidad de mantener
económicamente las operaciones digitales
según indica la ong espacio público
rcr Era uno de los pocos espacios que
había sido crítico con el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro y desde 2019 había estado
emitiendo su señal a través de YouTube
luego de que la Comisión Nacional de
telecomunicaciones se negará a
renovarles su licencia para seguir
operando esto se dio después de que
transmitiera el levantamiento contra
maduro liderado por Juan guaidó junto a
un grupo de militares en redes sociales
radio Caracas radio es recordada por sus
ex empleados o invitados como una voz de
libertad y coraje María Alejandra
Trujillo trabajó allí y nos habló sobre
las implicaciones que tiene este cierre
para la democracia y el acceso a la
información
desde que se inició
el proyecto que denominaron hegemonía
comunicacional son cientos de medios de
comunicación
radioeléctricos pero también impresos y
y digitales que que han salido del aire
que han sido cerrados quizás el caso más
emblemático el de radio Caracas
televisión en el año 2007 pero en el
caso concreto de empresas 1bc al que
formaba parte radio Caracas radio allí
hay que sumar a radio Caracas televisión
internacional 92.9 y el caso de rcr en
2019 y ahora recientemente
fuera de las plataformas digitales
Obviamente si no tienes
medios de comunicación es imposible que
la ciudadanía esté debidamente informada
y se trata de una política de estado son
cientos de medios de comunicación en el
caso concreto
de Venezuela que es el que el que
conozco si si no existen esas
plataformas es imposible que la
ciudadanía tenga acceso oportuno a la
información y sobre todo cuando hablamos
de un país como el nuestro donde se
aplica una política de oscurantismo con
relación al manejo transparente de la
información en todos los órdenes pero
obviamente es un golpe durísimo que va
en contra la democracia y un derecho
fundamental de los ciudadanos que es la
libertad de expresión y el libre acceso
a la información Andrés el mismo día en
que radio Caracas radio anunciaba su
cierre también lo hacía en Bolivia el
periódico página siete uno de los
principales medios de comunicación del
país y que había estado en
funcionamiento desde hace 13 años en un
texto publicado en su edición digital
sus trabajadores señalan que así
concluye una agotadora batalla y
explican que este es un momento que se
veía venir pero también recuerda que
página 7 fue uno de los medios más
premiados por más de una década y que
también fue uno de los pocos que marcó
huella con revelaciones que destaparon
hechos de corrupción y otros delitos su
director Raúl grafolik publicó una carta
en la que dice que la situación fue el
resultado de varios factores como
problemas financieros y hostigamiento
del oficialismo que describió como una
Tormenta perfecta
auditorías y multas recurrentes de una
diversidad de instituciones del estado
se enseñaron año tras año contra página
7 mientras nuestros competidores de
línea oficialista fueron tratados con
guante blanco aparte del acoso del poder
contra este diario independiente existen
otras razones que obligan a su cierre la
pandemia de covid cambió los hábitos de
lectura de noticias de la gente
generando una fuerte caída en la venta
de periódicos impresos lo que disminuyó
nuestros ingresos y para colmo el precio
Internacional del papel y otros insumos
de impresión se incrementó por efecto de
la guerra en Ucrania Este es un momento
duro que me llena de tristeza y angustia
porque soy consciente de que el
periodismo independiente y la democracia
pierden un Aliado importante
y es que hace más de un mes otro gran
medio de América Latina que cesaba sus
operaciones era el periódico en
Guatemala este diario que existía desde
1996 ya había detenido su edición
impresa en noviembre Pero seguía
publicándose de manera digital luego de
que su fundador José Rubén Zamora fuera
detenido acusado de blanqueo de
capitales y extorsión el año pasado
cargos que él mismo describió como una
persecución política ya que el periódico
había realizado importantes
investigaciones sobre corrupción
gubernamental finalmente la justicia
condenó a Zamora a seis años de cárcel
una decisión rechazada por políticos
asociaciones de periodistas y
organizaciones defensoras de Derechos
Humanos
según la más reciente clasificación
Mundial de la libertad de prensa de
reporteros Sin fronteras estos tres
países que hemos mencionado se ubican
bien abajo en una lista de 180 naciones
de ellos la peor clasificación la tiene
Venezuela en el puesto 158 donde esta
organización denunció que existe un
clima de restricción de la información
Guatemala se ubica en el lugar 127
reporteros Sin fronteras dice que allí
los periodistas y medios que investigan
o critican actos de corrupción y
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
suelen padecer represalias como campañas
de acoso y persecución penal mientras
que en Bolivia con el puesto 117 los
ataques hacia los periodistas se han
intensificados Especialmente los de la
policía a nivel latinoamérica Cuba
Honduras y Nicaragua se llevan la peor
parte de esta manera despedimos este
episodio de revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir este u otro capítulo
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer A
través de nuestra página web triple W
punto franz24.com
[Música]